A lot of us have fond memories of Halloween.
Dressing up in spooky costumes, wandering
around the neighborhood with friends while
trick or treating, getting home with literal
buckets full of candy, and then eating so
many sugary treats that you feel sick.
Halloween is a beloved holiday, especially
throughout many parts of the United States.
And if you were lucky enough to grow up in
a town that really went all out when the last
night of October rolled around, then you may
even have had a local Halloween themed fairground
to visit on the creepiest night of the year.
Scary rides, mazes, and jack o’ lanterns
as far as the eye can see.
But, with all that said, if you lived in a
certain town in the Midwest, then maybe the
county fair is a little more frightening than
the spirit of the Halloween season usually
encourages.
Settle in for a story of scares, a tale of
terror and a fable of frights, this is SCP-097,
also known as Old Fairgrounds.
Cordoned off by the SCP Foundation using huge
concrete walls is ten acres of rural land
in an undisclosed area of the Midwestern United
States.
The place itself is completely abandoned,
left silent and alone as everything contained
within those walls slowly falls into disrepair.
This is all that remains of the local County
Fair, held in the year 1969.
And right in the middle of it all?
A pickup truck, crushed and wrecked beyond
all use.
But this truck didn’t crash, oh no this
was no tragic roadside accident.
The thing that crushed it happened to be a
gigantic pumpkin.
Now, we aren’t just talking about a local
vegetable growing competition winner here.
When we say this is a big pumpkin, we are
talking huge.
The colossal squash has been recorded to measure
well over seven meters in height, with a diameter
just over eight meters at the widest point.
According to estimates, this pumpkin, known
as SCP-097-1, weighs an enormous 15,000 kilograms,
or 33,070 pounds.
To give you a frame of reference, that’s
about four times the average weight of a hippopotamus.
The pumpkin even manages to keep a perfectly
spherical shape, staying plump and round rather
than spreading out under its own weight, as
you might expect a plant of such size would.
Okay, a pickup truck crushed by a giant pumpkin?
You might be wondering, surely that can’t
be all there is?
Well, don’t you worry, we’re just getting
started with this creep show.
The rest of the surrounding area of SCP-097
is abundant in overgrown pumpkins, none that
quite reach the enviable size of SCP-097-1,
but plenty of all different subspecies and
types.
On average, these smaller pumpkins weigh around
250 kilograms, or 550 pounds.
Along with various other crops that have grown
within the area of SCP-097, the pumpkins seem
to have formed some kind of maze, no pun intended.
Get it, maize like corn?
These jokes are wasted on you.
Spooky mazes are no strange inclusion at rural
Halloween fairs like this one.
Getting lost in the middle of the night, surrounded
by rows of corn taller than a human being
is all part of the fun.
Makes a person feel like they’re right in
the middle of a classic eighties slasher movie,
where the killer could be creeping up behind
them any second.
The naturally formed labyrinth found within
SCP-097 has spread all throughout what is
left of the 1969 county fairgrounds, with
the “walls” of crops reaching over one
and a half meters tall, depending on the year.
So, is that all?
A maze of crops with one giant pumpkin at
its center?
Oh, that’s far from all there is to SCP-097.
During the time between April and November
of every year, a number of bizarre and anomalous
phenomena take place within this abandoned
county fairground, ranging from strange happenings
that defy explanation, to things that are
downright dangerous.
Since they first came into contact with SCP-097,
the Foundation have lost eight agents to the
phenomena that occur within that area, with
a another seventeen being severely maimed.
While the exact time of these events seems
to vary, the SCP Foundation keeps an extensive
record of phenomena that occur within SCP-097.
Now sometimes, these will be as harmless and
annoying as the sound of drums playing throughout
the day, for almost twenty four hours without
stopping.
Then, there’s the sightings of entities
moving through the maze only to disappear
after a few short seconds.
Security footage the Foundation’s agents
have gathered of these entities depict them
as what can only be described as “bed sheet
ghosts”, the kind you might see and immediately
think of as a last minute low budget Halloween
costume.
On one particular occasion, singing was heard
in the maze, coming from an unidentified source.
When analyzed, recordings made by the Foundation
revealed there were up to thirty children’s
voices, all singing in unintelligible gibberish
for three consecutive hours.
Another incident involved a member of personnel
on site, Agent McRoy, who cut a pumpkin vine
using a machete.
Horrifyingly, the severed vine bled.
By that we mean, actual human blood came pouring
out of the plant.
Another agent, on a separate occasion, was
also found dead within the SCP-097 maze.
Agent Long had disappeared on the way to the
restroom, only to be discovered lifeless and
bloodied, resting against a pumpkin.
During one weekly examination of SCP-097,
one Agent Cole broke open a pumpkin completely
by accident.
As the pumpkin split apart, however, to the
agent’s horror, a child’s skeleton was
revealed to be inside.
A human child’s skeleton, a little girl
crouched in the fetal position, believed to
only have been about five years of age.
Another incident saw O’Toole, a research
assistant working on site at SCP-097 experiencing
symptoms of nausea.
O’Toole also appeared to be vomiting pumpkin
seeds, despite not having eaten any recently.
Within a day, O’Toole was dead, seeming
to have died overnight in his sleep.
An autopsy conducted by Foundation experts
revealed that O’Toole’s chest cavity,
the space beneath his ribs, was somehow filled
with the same pumpkin seeds.
All of these happenings are strange to say
the least, but perhaps most concerning of
all is the effect that the abandoned fairground
of SCP-097 seems to have on children.
Any under or up to the age of ten years old
can fall victim to an unpredictable signal
that seems to emanate from SCP-097, with a
maximum range that is, as of yet, undetermined.
Usually beginning in early April, children
that are affected by this signal become afflicted
with somnambulism, or sleep walking as it
is more commonly known.
On clear nights, these children will wander
around their own homes, often only stopping
in front of closed doorways.
This behavior usually doesn’t happen often,
at least at first, only occurring once a week.
However, sleep walking gradually becomes more
frequent, and by around the middle of August,
it will be a nightly occurrence.
If children with this affliction are ever
woken up while sleepwalking, they will scream
for several seconds, before appearing confused.
This seems to be the only known way to break
the influence of SCP-097.
However, if left undisturbed, a child will
spend their sleep walking episodes familiarizing
themselves with the doorways of their house.
They will stop at every entrance, exit, garage
door, gate, even the neighbors’ front doors
once they find a way outside.
From September, the sleepwalking children
will stay outside, upright but asleep until
the sun comes up.
Many are often found laying on the grass in
their gardens, and commonly recall having
dreams about autumn-season activities.
Between September first and November first,
any affected child not awoken during their
sleepwalking will begin to migrate towards
SCP-097’s location.
All while still unconscious, they will traverse
country roads, cutting across large empty
fields, as they gradually make their way towards
the abandoned remains of the county fairground.
Once there, they will even be able to blindly
navigate a path through the maze that surrounds
most of SCP-097, until they find the center.
What happens when they make it to the center
of the maze?
Any sleepwalking children who are able to
make it that far will seek out SCP-097-1,
the gigantic pumpkin crushing the truck in
the middle of the SCP-097 area.
The children will then sit down around the
almost 23 foot tall pumpkin, and begin to
sing.
Even though the SCP Foundation have managed
to make recordings of this, much of the singing
seems to be gibberish, or at least not sung
in any known language.
However, music will also begin playing from
an unknown source, seeming to include a number
of basic instruments, most commonly simple
drums and pipes.
After the sleepwalking children have spent
a number of minutes singing like this, that
is when things take a turn for the far, far
worse, like a Charlie Brown Halloween special
straight out of your most horrific nightmares.
From the tangled mess of plants that make
up the maze within SCP-097, things will start
to emerge.
These entities will crawl out of the surrounding
flora, or will come bursting out from within
the larger of the nearby pumpkins.
They appear to be childlike in both their
appearance and mannerisms, some even wearing
pajamas or similar clothing.
Why?
Simple, because these are the children that
sleep walked before.
They are all previous victims, the ones stolen
from their families and brought into this
maze.
Still wearing the clothes that they were last
seen in; they are all the children known to
be lost to SCP-097.
What happens next is truly chilling.
The latest child that has been affected by
the draw of the pumpkin-filled fairground
will be quickly surrounded by all their fellow
victims.
The other children, if they are in fact still
human children, will encircle the newest child,
singing and dancing around them in a circle.
As they do this, a dim light begins to glow
from somewhere within SCP-097-1, the biggest
pumpkin in the center of SCP-097.
Finally, at this point in the process, the
newly affected child will wake up.
Normally, they experience a great deal of
terror and confusion.
After all, they have been unconscious throughout
this entire ordeal, sleepwalking far away
from the safety of their own home to a maze
in the middle of nowhere.
Terror is a powerful thing, enough to make
even the bravest person let out a scream.
But the moment the now awakened child lets
out any sound, that is when they are doomed.
Should they scream, cry or make any form of
vocal noise, then the others will swarm them.
The other children, the ones previously lured
into SCP-097 while sleep walking, will attack
the terrified newcomer.
Each time is different, sometimes they will
claw at the new child, other times they might
bite or kick.
The methods are always different, but most
often this swarm of the pumpkin’s previous
victims will strangle or dismember the latest
visitor to the abandoned fairground.
At this point, there is no saving the latest
victim.
Any attempt to interfere will only fail, either
the children will all become intangible, or
another violent phenomenon will occur within
SCP-097, stopping any onlooker from saving
the child’s life.
When the deed is finally done, and the latest
victim has been killed by the other children,
the gigantic pumpkin at the heart of SCP-097
will open.
Its side will split like a pair of great,
devouring jaws, and the children will throw
the body of the newest child into SCP-097-1.
Once the body has been disposed of, these
entities, once children that sleep walked
away from their families, will follow, crawling
into the pumpkin before it closes and the
music finally stops.
The exact number of children between the ages
of three and ten years of age who have been
lost to SCP-097 is currently kept secret by
the Foundation.
And perhaps, for all of our sanities, that
is for the best.
Like we said, a lot of us have fond memories
of Halloween.
But not all of us...
Now go check out “SCP-823 - Carnival of
Horrors” and “SCP Herman Fuller's Circus
of the Disquieting” for more creepy carnivals
and unsettling circuses!